hello there I'm gap I'm Dan and a lot of
people on the internet Dan have
commented on the state of your lab coat
look at it tell me this absolutely
gulping look at it brag order blood bag
watermelon paint
we lost the sleeve yeah very early holes
we've stuck with it but I think it's
time for a replacement
yeah and tied have stepped up to the
plate and given you a brand-new white
lab coat weed bong that on look at this
so much too bright for eyes yeah is it
fit as well now enjoy the cleanliness
for a moment have you enjoyed it yeah
all right now we're gonna get it really
day and see if they can wash it out
Martha write down you got your goggles
on yeah my body is excellent here we go
starting with ketchup
this just isn't gonna do is it oh I'll
be right back oh yeah what is that
thoughts uh this can actually what
incoming go in the jugular with it oh
you can see the recoil whoa yeah Jesus
that was really direct that she is
lovely
look at you oh hey my throat literally
took a joke around
I've never fired a gorg boop blaster
candor I would say that's it's pretty
solid eh she's disgusting fully gross
yeah Oh didn't see that before
Oh Oh all right Dan I've reloaded this
thing with some chocolate pudding oh joy
are you ready yeah gonna fire sure is it
delicious though I mean chocolate
yeah but chocolate mix with ketchup
absolutely not Gusti
oh listen up with shot I don't believe
it knocked your goggles oh please not
not with goggles off history look at
that spread can you actually see my
people because I can't see down the lens
with that chocolate milk chocolate
pudding in my eye though it's dripping
out oh ha ha
I can't even wipe it off with my hands
they're coming in this way everyone
always disturbing things I've ever
filmed ah slightly better ha ha so
chocolate pudding makes quite good hair
gel actually move on to some different
colors maybe baby get chocolate chip ice
cream so this is mint chocolate chip
chocolate chip oh okay you just gave me
straight my face right now that just
mean Dan excellent got you right in the
face I accidentally on purpose you think
he'll over yeah
well I'm not being funny then that might
be the most fun I've ever had making a
slim agrestic
I was absolutely honking I feel
disgusting it's gross you read all these
flavors to me now
yeah don't it's not worth it yeah
well it's now up to tide to try and get
this lab coat clean yeah thanks to you
they've gone they've got their work out
they do indeed you can watch that
process over on the tide channel by
clicking the link in the description
below feel free to follow us on Twitter
subscribe to us by shirt yeah yeah not
this one you definitely don't on that
one but you know that feeling where you
get something sticky on your hands it's
kind of sticky really annoying
especially when you but yeah but really
annoying yeah oh that's gross yeah I've
got that all over my body
that is unfortunate look before we gonna
splat me with it after Wow can I be a
hug if you want
you